the warring sides in Yemen's conflict
have released more detainees for a third
and final day as part of a large-scale
prisoner exchange this is the latest
group of houthi presidents to arrive in
the rebel control Capital Sanaa dozens
of troops from the side of UAE Coalition
are also being released the Red Cross
says more than 900 prisoners from both
sides have been freed in the operation
The Exchange is part of a broader
diplomatic effort to end the eight-year
long conflict Fatima Seton is a
spokesman for the international
Committee of the Red Cross and she's
joining us from Sanaa very good to have
you with us I understand that you have
been on some of the planes that have
been carrying these prisoners these
former prisoners back what has the mood
been like on the planes
yes indeed I I was on the on several
planes
um yesterday from from sanah before
yesterday from Adams somehow and and
today I just returned right now from the
from the airport uh it's uh it's a very
it's it's such an amazing moment and
it's such a beautiful
Moment full of happiness and joy that we
can witness at the airport every time
and it's um it's needed and it's it's
really glimpse of Hope
um and you know those operations are all
about reunifying families so this week
nearly 900 detainees were reignified
with their families which means like
over thousands of people will be able to
spend eight together this year as I
mentioned before we're not just seeing
um who the prisoners being returned to
Sanaa we're obviously seeing
um prisoners who have been held troops
from the Saudi UAE Coalition have been
returned as well have you been on those
flights and is there a difference in
feeling between those flights
is that uh so this is this is a very
heavily and complex logistically
speaking operation
um we just conducted 15 flights uh
carrying nearly 900 detainees we have
got four planes dedicated to that and
happening in six cities around Yemen but
also in Saudi
um and uh so not only the logistic is uh
is is heavy but our role here at the
international Committee of the Red Cross
goes beyond only taking detainees from A
to B our wall here is also to to apply
our protection mandate which means that
my colleagues our teams were able to
visit those detainees in private before
they they board on the plates weeks
before a treat was one of the conditions
to conduct this operation and during
those visits we were able to check if
they had any special needs if they were
aware just to explain to them the
operation and also to make sure that
they were okay to be released and then
when they arrive we also we give them
the opportunity
to call their families and they also get
a small box for iftar to break the
evening meal so it is beyond only a
logistical operation
have you had a chance to see any of the
conditions that people in Yemen have
been living in over the last few years
the Assumption has been because Yemen
has been off the international media
radar for want of a better phrase the
news agenda for so long that things have
quietened down but clearly that is not
the case
is that just Yemen doesn't do the
headline and the things that even if the
conflict had to end tomorrow the needs
are still huge and the words shouldn't
forget about about this and also it's
it's important to acknowledge that
actually many more families are waiting
for answers from their loved ones many
families don't know if they if their
loved ones is wondered if they're
detained or if they're even alive so of
course this is a very positive momentum
but it's also important to remind that
many other families deserve more answers
do you get the sense that people believe
that this is now the road to a proper
ceasefire a proper permanent truce or is
there a sense that people are very wary
of any negotiations and what the future
might hold
only a political uh way will uh will be
the solution to this conflict
um so of course any any talks any
negotiation that will lead to
alleviating civilian suffering and who
lead to peace is more than welcome
Fatima Saida we appreciate you being
with us on Al Jazeera thank you very
much indeed man thank you
thank you bye